[Music]
popcorn sometimes sweet and salt but
when they need sweet buying middle never
fight not too far front a lot too far
for the back oh my god that
chocolate-covered little piece of bubbly
never go front row title of your memoirs
you never go from right in the middle
pence on the theater is there a balcony
jalapenos processed cheese Cellmark
bottom middle there's popcorn with M&Ms
mixed in and then there's a Diet Coke
but then there's water to pretend I'm
not having the night coke about halfway
up but a little close to the front on
the aisle more for Ben he's weird about
the aisle eight isn't what I feel
trapped I'm always like have you ever
been trapped there's a real real feeling
about that I like to eat a lot of pop
one when I was in my twenties yeah I
would definitely mix the sweet and salty
but that's like a whole meal I like to
be in the middle of the screen well I'm
a great multitasker so I enjoy locking
my eyes onto the screen also well you
should have popcorn gummy bears in the
south that's cute
popcorn with all the butter popcorn is
butter there's something very American I
like like a left center and I don't want
to be directly in the middle because it
kind of freaks me out makes me feel like
I'm in a screening going to 3d movie you
got to sit in the front row there's no
frame and you're literally in the 3d
yeah but I'm front row at the first
showing of the day because I have a
thing called
misophonia if I hear people eating
popcorn on Apple near my ear people are
talking in a movie can't stand my rage
goes off the charts so instantaneously
it's okay if I'm eating popcorn I can't
have it if anybody else is doing it in
on M&Ms every single time some buttered
popcorn because I always sit in the back
half and to the left if I could I would
buy like
whole row and just sort of insulate
myself I mix it up pop - Oh nachos
I'm back to the aisle in kiss a weak
Constitution or something of the good
oh so I don't eat I don't like people
eating in cinema I am busy [ __ ] my two
hours time in my life and my dad I want
to give it to them and like enjoy this
day look I love sitting in the middle
[Music]